Determine whether the
statement is always,
sometimes, or never true,
and explain why.
The statement here is b squared
plus b minus 2, all of
that over b plus 2 is equal
to b minus 1 for all
real numbers b.
Well one thing that just jumps
out at you before you even try
to manipulate this algebraically
is that I can
think of a b value where this
left expression won't be equal
to b minus 1.
A b value that will make this
left expression undefined.
And it becomes undefined if this
denominator becomes 0.
And the way the denominator is
going to become 0 is if b is
negative 2.
So let's write that down.
If b is equal to negative 2,
then b squared plus b minus 2
over b plus 2, what
does that become?
It equals-- b squared would be 4
minus 2 minus 2, which would
be 0/0, which is undefined.
It's not equal to-- let me
write this this way.
It's not equal to b minus 1,
which is-- negative 2 minus 1,
negative 3.
When you put negative 2 in here,
on the left-hand side,
it doesn't evaluate
to negative 3.
It evaluates to 0/0,
which is undefined.
So we already found an example
of a b where this is not true.
So it's definitely not always
going to be true.
We found a case.
Now, let's algebraically
manipulate this and see if
it's true for pretty much
any other number.
So let's see if we can maybe
factor the numerator up there.
So b squared plus b minus 2.
If you think about it, two
numbers when you take their
product is negative 2, and when
you add them you get 1.
Well, that's going to be
positive 2 and negative 1.
So the numerator we can
rewrite as b plus 2
times b minus 1.
And then the denominator
is b plus 2.
Well we can just leave
it like that.
Let's just work on the
left-hand side.
Now, if we assume that b is not
equal to negative 2, then
b plus 2 divided by b plus
2 is well defined.
It is 1.
As long as it's not
0/0 it will be 1.
And so this expression is the
same thing as b minus 1 if we
assume that b is not equal
to negative 2.
So if you assume that b is not
equal to negative 2, this
thing over here does indeed
equal b minus 1.
So it is true for all of the
other real numbers except for
negative 2.
So this is sometimes true.
It's true every time except for
the case where b is equal
to negative 2.
And you can even try it
with some number here.
Try it with 0.
If I were to do 0 squared plus 0
minus 2, you get negative 2.
Over 0 plus 2 is 2.
And then that does indeed
equal negative 1.
So it works with 0,
it works with 1.
It'll work with any number
other than b is equal to
negative 2.